hey everybody i'm jake johnson from
netflix's hoops
today i'm doing something with buzzfeed
i'm going to be reading your
thirsty tweets let's begin
let jake johnson read thirst tweets i
want him to know i want to
lick him from head to toe well i'm gonna
tell you if you're gonna lick me from
head to toe
you're gonna want me to be out of the
shower first there's some zones
no human needs to lick i wish for jake
johnson to swaddle me
in one of those claws baby bjorn wraps
and put me to sleep you know that's kind
of a sweet one
yeah i'll wrap you up with a baby i know
those little uh babybjorn things you're
talking about
and i know how to do them okay netflix
you got me jake johnson as a hairy
[ __ ]
foul mouth coaches everything i've ever
wanted where on that show am i hairy
you just added that yes i'm [ __ ] in it
i'm foul mouth and i am a coach
is coach ben harry i would let nick
miller and schmidt from new girl
really into the next century
sorry had to say it well after playing
nick miller for seven years in
plain opposite max greenfield who played
schmidt for those seven years
those two would not nail anything
together i'm not sure that would happen
the only thing that those two would nail
into the next century could
possibly be each other jake johnson's
beard
that's the tweet okay good tweet jake
johnson with
beard is the yummiest starter main
course
and dessert together all right thank you
i did not know that jake johnson was in
spider-verse
and when i heard his voice i became
instantly wet well thank you for that uh
tweet sir i
i appreciate that i hope you dry off
buddy list of things i want jake
johnson to do to me fight me nick miller
style
scream at my face like chris vale in a
life-threatening
experience would repeatedly whisper
whip and release in my ears sing me deck
the halls to sleep
five hug me i guess she was playing imdb
for the first four
number five that one's just her i'm
gonna watch the money just because
jake johnson is in it and i'm a whole
friend
don't let your parents on your twitter
all porn
should just be jake johnson playing a
bartender no sex
just jake johnson behind the bar is good
thanks it seems potentially like a start
i'm not sure there'd be a lot of
finishing as they say i don't see that
as the most popular
hit popular opinion actor jake johnson's
nose is a sex icon
i think that would be an unpopular
opinion maybe a
niche opinion this nose is no sex icon
and i'm going to prove it if you look
underneath it doesn't go all the way up
it got broke here by a kid named kenono
if you're watching it i'm still bringing
it up that's when we were 15 years old
okay jake johnson's nose is a salt of
the earth
knows wow what a nose that nose will be
there for you
if you tell that no that you can't sleep
can it stay on the phone until you
fall asleep that nose will do that until
it says
i'm outside your door but not in a
creepy wood and it'll fix the cabinet
door that never shot all the way before
i would say that's the most interesting
tweet that i've personally read
that's a lot about minos jake johnson
if you are reading this please come
choke me
jake johnson if you're reading this
please come choke me
the f out right now i really need
the death by boxer
thank you i promise you i would love
stumptown
even if it didn't feature jake johnson
wearing a beard
and a rotating selection of trailblazers
t-shirts while he pours beers
and actively listens but it does feature
all those things so i never
stood a chest is that the correct term
wearing a beard
literally everything about jake johnson
a long list again about the face
his scrunchy face his facial hair his
raspy voice
i'm gonna move on from this one those
just seem like compliments and they're
embarrassing
gonna take a break from being political
that to say that i want jake johnson to
rob me
well here's what i will say about that
i'm glad we're all taking a break from
being political all the time especially
on social media let's get back to
just writing about wanting somebody to
raw ya well now i know
after reading these why i'm no longer on
twitter please check out hoops it comes
out on netflix
august 21st
you